foreign
hey everybody what's going on we're
awfully close yeah what the [__]
happened here
I guess we're closer to the table than
usual yeah that's probably what it is
and I think the laptop is kind of
shifted
positions everything that's about right
that Spock is moving but it's not really
moving by itself because Pookie is
messing with his leg again it's all that
light oh it's um actually
that's off the ceiling yeah white
ceiling there you go
there you go
there you go all right so we get we got
it yeah I think all right all right so
how's everybody doing it's Sunday
evening at least Where We Are
and we are talking about this great
[__] movie here I think this is one
of the ones that we brought up on Friday
night
because I had never seen it because I
had wrote down uh you know because
people had been making suggestions and
stuff and then I thought to myself I was
like oh I've been wanting to do this
movie for a while
weird thing about this movie though is
that it's not officially streaming
anywhere like I looked it up and you
know how when you Google a movie and it
says you know here's all your options
you can rent it for 2.99 on YouTube or
Amazon Prime or whatever nothing there's
nothing there happily though uh several
people have put this movie Up on YouTube
uh for free and that's in like in HD
yeah it looks good so that's where we
watched it I have no idea why it's not
available to officially stream anymore
must be some kind of Licensing problem
like I figure that if it's not then
that's totally legit for people to be
putting that up so that's how we watched
it something to do with licensing well
obviously it must be but it's just like
I don't know and that's what you know
what okay so this like makes me really
mad because I [__] love this movie
okay I've seen it probably three or four
times maybe five times I've seen it
several times I actually saw this movie
in the theater when it first came out
back in 2000
and it didn't
um do very well commercially I think it
did make I think it only cost like six
million to make or something like that
and it made like 11.5 million back which
you know not great so it wasn't really
much of a success however it was uh a
critical darling and it got nominated
for a couple of oscars uh for makeup and
Willem Dafoe got nominated for best
supporting actor um but neither of them
got it unfortunately yeah this movie
here is a star-studded masterpiece
and it's it's [__] awesome I love
this movie so much it's about the making
of the movie
uh Nosferatu which is a German rip-off
of [__] Dracula
the director could not this is real this
is a real Story in real life the
director could not secure the licenses
for Dracula the Widow of uh Bram Stoker
wouldn't wouldn't let him have
so he kind of rewrote the story around a
fictional vampire named count Warlock
um
now
it it was evidently a real good movie
you can get it
but the licensing issue [__] came up
anyway and they made them destroy this
movie and only one copy survived
it almost was lost to history which
would have been really sad because the
original Nosferatu is awesome yeah and
it's it's a silent film
and Nosferatu or count warlock is played
by an actor named Max Shrek
and in the movie he appears he's just he
looks like me
he's this bald dude with big point of
red ears and like [__] weird looking
faces like rat teeth and he's in this
[__] weird coat you know I think he
looks great big old long figures big
long fingernails just walks around real
unnatural looking
eyes are all [__] up and everything
and uh
Max Shrek played him
now in real life
nobody knew much about Mac Shrek and
this is evidently the only movie that he
made no I looked it up later he actually
was in a bunch of other movies he was
all right but I think at the time like I
think everybody knows that now but I
think at the time that he made this
movie
um the makeup and [__] like that was so
good that a rumor started going around
he was really about that he was really a
vampire and that's where this movie
comes in yes this is very fanciful all
of the people in this like all the
characters are in this are real people
are based on real people yeah but
they're not they took a lot of lives but
it's okay
what they're doing with this one is is
that they're running with the story yeah
yeah they made that movie Nosferatu and
Max Shrek was just a stage name for a
real vampire director found out in a
castle
and made the movie around him
and uh so the movie is about making
Nosferatu
and there's a real vampire and only
director knows he's real yeah the rest
of the cast don't know that that's a
real vampire they think it's a method
act yeah and real good makeup yeah but
no he's he's a [__] vampire and he's
killing them killing the crew the the
the and the [__] directors like I
told you told me you will not harm my
people the director's played by [__]
job he [__] knocks it out of the park
I mean he's crazy as [__] like he's like
he malkovic's his way through this it's
great and then you go but they got udok
here
he's the producer he's the producer and
he's on the ground which was also a real
person and that dude just does what he
does that I love it creepy freaky
Udo
what was that movie that we saw him in
where he would played that [__] like
a doctor Frankenstein type guy who was
well it was the Andy Warhol one like
flesh for Americans yeah that's right
Andy were all fresh for Frankenstein I
love it man it's great you know care was
also in Suspiria although it was like a
pretty small part actually and Max
schret the the vampire is played by
William Defoe and Defoe knocks it out of
the [__] he's so [__] good at this
I thought he looks like a ghost I
thought he was great in in Spider-Man as
the goblin he's [__] greatest [__]
count warlock or the this vampire
he's just creepy as [__] and he's just
oh man
and what's weird about him is he's got
all the same
he's immortal
but he's kind of got all the same he's
real sad and he's got all these weird
human frailties you know he doesn't
remember much about his past and just he
just thinks about everything they lost
in life and how he used to be a famous
General and now he couldn't even have
servants and he had to make food for
people he hadn't made food and
that's what made him sad about the book
Dracula yeah was that because he could
relate you know he could relate to that
because he hadn't eaten forever you know
and uh he was eating and it's just some
funny [__] happens he's he's the cast is
trying to hang out with him
you know this vampire they think he's
like come on did you take the take those
silly ears off that kind of type of
stuff
and they're just trying to get him to
you know talk
and
he won't break character though from
their point of view it's like he's not
breaking character he's still talking
like he's a vampire he was a vampire in
the middle of the conversation he
reaches up and grabs a bat the fluid
flies by and just starts eating and
they're just like they were drinking
they were drinking schnapps he the
vampire was drinking yeah
later on there says yeah I knew he was a
vampire he saw me he ate that bad he
goes no he was drunk he's drunk like
just you know you get drunk eat bats you
know well I love that he did that and
then like the other two guys are like
what an actor
like he's like all in for this [__] well
the funny thing is like the the premise
of this is hilarious
slasher friend points out the plot of
the movie is very much similar to Wes
Craven's New Nightmare yeah kinda
because it's sort of uh what if like
what if Mack truck was actually a
vampire uh Richard Brown said isn't uh
isn't Eddie Izzard in it yes he is he
plays um and I love Eddie as are you
guys yeah
um but he uh plays like the the leading
man
in the same movie every weird dude you
can think of is in this movie and guess
who produced this [__] Nicholas
Nicholas Cage he should have been in it
well he was actually he was going to be
Max Shrek oh okay yeah that was like the
original thing yeah I don't know if it
would have been quite the same no no
well because the things oh man because
well oh my God this is probably and
there's a lot of competition that's
because I love Willem Dafoe but this I
think is probably my favorite
performance of his yeah he's great he's
so [__] good in this yeah and I wish
he'd won the Oscar he did get nominated
at least but he's just so [__] creepy
man like the [__] facial expressions
he makes and stuff like that oh my God
it's so [__] great yeah he can do
it's so good but it's like well okay so
like when you if you haven't seen the
movie it's kind of hard to explain
because I'm not really sure what genre
even I would place it as because it's
not it's kind of like a horror movie
sort of it's horror
um it's kind of like a drama but it's
kind of like a black comedy too yeah but
I don't want to go too far in that
direction because it's not like zany I
feel like the comedy is more just kind
of like grim and sort of like
understated well it's also the comedy
isn't how bizarre all these characters
are yeah like it's not super overt
pretty much bizarre it's a bizarre crazy
German
film dudes yeah wearing white coats and
[__] goggles when they're filming and
and it's accurate evidently to the way
things were filmed back then they put
these goggles on so it would so they can
see what it would look like when it was
black and white I mean I assumed that's
what it was because I wasn't really sure
they're gonna put them on and then they
would show it black and white sometimes
so I think yeah it helped them see what
it's kind of like welding goggles yeah
or you know why the lab coats though we
don't know about that because like a
Zion tip it because they're doing
science scientific high-tech [__]
because they're Germans that's how they
do it filming was high-tech [__]
well I mean it well it was very much in
its infancy this was like when they were
making the movie it's like 1921 right
because the movie came out in 1922. so
it's that but well the thing about it so
John Malkovich who plays um fwmer now
you know the guy that directed Nosferatu
now they did take a lot of license with
the actual person of fwmer now who
um because in this movie they're trying
to make John Malcolm but she's like
almost as crazy as the vampire is
because he's like completely dictatorial
and he yeah and and like he doesn't care
about anything except his art and like
getting this movie made he doesn't give
a [__] like at the vampire I mean he
gives a [__] it kills a lot of the crew
but yeah like a lot of the crew get
killed but it's like as long as he gets
the shot like it's fine because he wants
this movie made for posterity and that's
like all he cared about now obviously
like the real guy FW burnout was
actually not like that at all like he
was actually uh quite a uh quite a nice
guy like at least according to everybody
that knew him yeah it wouldn't work the
story but yeah it wouldn't work in the
story because I really like the way I
mean like I said the film it's very
uh fanciful in the way that it's coming
at filmmaking and it's almost kind of
like it's sort of making like a meta
statement about uh like film versus
reality you know what I mean because
there's a lot of that kind of like
theming in there like especially like
toward the end where John Malkovich says
uh you know and the vampire's like
killing all these people on the set and
he just keeps on filming it it's like he
doesn't give a [__] and then he just
says something like he says if it's not
in frame it doesn't exist yeah so
they're kind of like so so like I said
that part of that yeah so it's kind of
like making a meta statement about the
reality of uh like reality versus film
and it's like you know so it's kind of
like it has a deeper meaning to that too
but what was great about it is that they
wrote the movie around the Nosferatu
film and they show they tell you this
story
in a way
no they okay
they wrote the story and they shot it in
a way
that makes the movie Nosferatu the one
you can go see what really happened yeah
in other words
the death scene that you see in the
Nosferatu film this movie says that that
was real like he really he really did
fade out and all that [__] all that was
everything you see in that movie like
that yeah that ship was a set we had to
make that set because he couldn't get
Dracula on it on the ship because he
wouldn't do it so we just don't know
because it was just a cheap set so
everything so when you watch that movie
at all it would all link back in to uh
into this movie Shadow the vampire oh
that explains why that scene looks like
[__] yeah you know what I mean [__]
yeah it's it's a genius it is like I
said that is [__] it is [__] yeah but
it's like but not in like a winky winky
like clever kind of way you know what I
mean but like the more times you see it
like the the cleverer it is you know
what I mean yeah and this was in case
you didn't know this was directed by um
e Elias murhish is I think how you
pronounce his last name who um if you
know anything about like weird ass cult
films also directed probably one of the
granddaddies of the weird ass [__]
cult films which is begotten which came
out in 1991 which is [__] weird as
[__] and he shot that as though it was
an actual silent movie from the actual
silent era so like it's all black and
white there's no dialogue it's all
grotty looking it looks like it came
from that time period and it's um it's
something it's uh I wrote a big long
thing about it like a long time ago
but it's like super nightmarish so he
was kind of like the the perfect person
to film this because he clearly has a
great love for the silent film era and
for filmmaking in general just like as
an art form so I really like that he was
kind of the one to tackle this I had
forgotten like for some reason like I
said I saw this in the theater and I've
seen it a couple times subsequently and
it always makes me sad that like a lot
of people haven't seen it especially
considering what a [__] amazing cast
it has and just like what amazing uh
acting performances it has Yeah Eddie is
ours is in this um Carrie Elwes is in
this uh he kind of plays Fritz who's the
guy that well because the vampire
uh [__] up the cinematographer like on
the down low you know what I mean
because the whole deal
the whole deal is that fwmer now is the
only one that knows that Max Shrek Is
For Real a vampire like he doesn't tell
any of the crew like I said he just
tells him he's a method actor so
everybody's like oh wow he's amazing and
he won't like let them see him like
before you know the the shoot that
they're doing
and so what they find out later is that
he actually promised Max track that he
could eat uh Greta who is you know the
the ingenue like the main actress like
in the movie because he kind of has a
thing for her so he promised the actress
to him and that's like how he got him to
do the movie yeah but he doesn't tell
but nobody knows that until like the
very end so he's like basically like
sacrificing people
for very similitude like in his movie
this is like one of my favorite things
is like the first time like there's a
great scene where it's the first time
that the cast and crew see Max Shrek so
like they're doing a scene and like
Eddie is Art Is there he's playing like
the main uh you know uh what's his name
Verner or Wagner or something like that
I can't remember what his name is Verner
I think and um so he's kind of like
going in the castle and then like he you
know Max Shrek like comes creeping out
of the [__] whatever and everybody's
looking I'm like holy [__] like he looks
like really [__] up like because he
looks all he's got all like his makeup
quote unquote that they think is his
makeup and then um so like the producer
who was udokir he leans over to John
Malkovich and he says where did you find
him and he says in that hole
and they're just like what so yeah so he
doesn't tell anybody
that he found this actual vampire I
think he's like in the the Czech
Republic or something like that right
because they filmed the first part of it
in Berlin because that's where the movie
starts out and then just like okay now
we have to go to the Czech Republic
because that's where the actor is that's
playing count orlock and he'll only like
he's a super method actor it's like you
can you can only interact with him in
character we can only shoot him at night
um all this other kind of [__] so it's
like super mysterious and like nobody
can see him you know what I mean but
then like as time goes on
um he starts well at first like
um myrnow gives him like bottles of
blood and he gives him a ferret at one
point like in a cage and stuff but after
a while like Shrek starts getting like
all pissed off so he just starts kind of
sucking on members of the crew yeah and
it's and another one of the funniest
scenes too is like when John Malkovich
goes in there like confronts him like if
you didn't because he um was starting to
like eat his he didn't kill him at first
but he just like was draining his blood
you know so he was kind of getting all
ill and passing out and whatever and so
he that was his cinematographer and he
was basically yelling he's like that
wasn't the deal like I said you could
have Greta at the end but it's like you
said that you wouldn't hurt any of my
crew or anything like that and but you
can tell that Shrek is getting like a
little antsy uh one to eat some of the
people and he's like asking about are
aren't there any like people on the set
that like you don't really need or
anything like that it's like the script
girl like you know what I mean we don't
really need the writer do we like all
that other kind of stuff so he can eat
them like I said what murder Hunter
saying that the full show is on YouTube
yeah yeah please you can see that's the
only place you can see it like several
people uploaded it in HD which I'm happy
for because I was very upset when I saw
that you couldn't officially stream it
anywhere the copy that we saw I don't
remember who posted it oh I don't
remember the name of the of who posted
it but uh it was HD quality it was just
like you're watching a Blu-ray or a DVD
yeah yeah and uh there was I think you
had to watch commercials though didn't
you no
um yeah yeah yeah yeah there were a
couple commercials but like I said
several people have uploaded it which
like I said I'm happy about because I
can't speak so we don't we haven't seen
those copies though we don't know how
good they are there's at least one of
them that's good yeah but like I said it
does have ads yeah but you know that's
okay yeah well well worth seeing it's
free yeah well because that was the
thing I had written down like a bunch of
movies uh to consider like for doing the
show because I think some people
mentioned like body heat and cereal mom
and stuff like that then I was thinking
about doing those but those who had to
pay to rent them and then I was like
shadow of the vampire was like oh hey
Blake somebody has that for free because
I think I watched it a couple years back
but I think it was on 2B for a little
while but it wasn't on there anymore but
it just I don't know it just makes me
really sad that like people don't really
talk about this movie all that much
because I mean it's old they came out in
2000 but it's real well it's so good
it's so good it's real well made it's a
period piece like taking place in the
1920s but bunch of wild [__] happens in
it all-star cast of freakazoids
um
everybody knocks out of the park
everybody one of the best Bad vampire
movies I've seen
yeah and I mean it technically is a
vampire movie like I said I don't know
I guess it's a horror movie I guess it's
a horror movie yeah it definitely has
horror yeah it's like a Gothic horror
movie but like I said it also has like
black comedy yeah to it too just because
of the absurdity of the situation freaks
man right crazy and yeah everybody is
like a [__] character yeah you know
what I mean it's just like and [__]
Carrie always is funny in this too like
I gotta say his German accent is a
little yeah odd but um but that's okay
like it kind of all just rolls together
with the with the [__] like when he
turns up on the set and asks if the
camera's loaded and they're like yeah
and he's like so am I and he's like
shooting the guns and everything like
trying to scare all the towns folk but
it's like there's just so many [__]
funny lines in this and the weird thing
about it too is that this very easily
and you know in no shade against
Nicholas Cage because he did produce
this movie I kind of feel like if
Nicholas Cage had played Max Shrek I
kind of worry that it might have gotten
like a Vampire's Kiss Direction which
don't get me wrong Vampire's Kiss is
awesome I love that movie but that was
like said in the modern day and it was
supposed to be more of like a comedy
comedy this one was kind of more a
historical drama horror movie but with
black comedy elements so I don't know if
it would have worked as well going too
far over the top defos defoe's portrayal
a light spot on the way he looked in the
uh in the silent film so he had
something to work with the the
mannerisms the facial expressions
that's the way nosferage actually looked
yeah and he's doing this when they're
not filming him that's that's just his
normal because that's what he was like
you look like normally and he acted like
that normally and he's weird real
[__] weird just the way he moves when
he walks around is weird he's real
uncomfortable with himself
I liked too that he really imbued the
character with
you know yeah obviously he's kind of
like a monster and he just wants what he
wants but he's also a little bit I don't
know if I'd go so far as today's
character sympathetic but
um pitiful yeah that's a good word way
of putting it like he's just he's really
sad and you can really and I think
that's one of the best things about
Willem dafoe's performance is that you
can really feel like the weight of all
of these centuries that he's lived and
how lonely he is yeah you know what I
mean and I borrowed from Klaus Kinski a
little bit
that I was kind of thinking that from
that from that from that movie yeah
because Klaus Kinski did a real good job
he's just [__] weird weird freaky and
beautiful Klaus Kinski is like uh pretty
much yeah so I think him out of he might
have looked at both of those movies and
I kind of feel like too that the maybe
the idea for the dynamic between Max
track and FW murnau in this film not in
real life maybe was inspired a little
bit by the real life relationship
between Klaus Kinski and Verna Herzog
yeah because that was like very
contentious and they were always like
screaming at each other all the time
so so that might have been like part of
the idea for for that as well Richard
Brown said wasn't the real max Shrek a
bit of an enigma yeah that's the thing I
had always heard that as well I looked
up just out of curiosity because I don't
know where I heard this but I always
heard that oh the reason that the rumor
sprung up that Max Shrek was like really
a vampire what the [__] was up with that
dude was because nosferashi was the only
film that he did but when I looked up
his Wikipedia page earlier that is not
the case he actually did a lot of films
um prior to Nosferatu and afterward
um and it's weird because I had never
seen a picture of him
outside of the Nosferatu makeup so I had
no idea what he really looked like what
did he look like
um weird looking okay he's weird looking
but I mean he didn't look like I mean he
was very striking looking he did you
could tell that you know that that was
kind of the roles that he was going to
be playing because just because the way
he looked because of the way he looked
like he wasn't like grotesque or
anything like that but he did have like
a very specific kind of
character actor kind of look to him I
guess but as that just like struck me as
really funny I was like yeah it just
occurred to me that I didn't even know
what Max Shrek looked like in real life
like without that makeup on because I
have to say like the makeup in the
original nosferato
I was looking at it again
like looking at Stills up because I've
seen Nosferatu like a bunch of times the
original one but the makeup in that is
really good
I mean that he looks like a [__] rat
man it doesn't even really look like
makeup
yeah which is low resolution back then
that see that probably yeah the way the
lenses work could be easy to fool your
eye because the image is kind of not
real crisp so but it's very artistic it
looks good yeah it looks so it's like
really unsettling because he really
looks like inhuman I'd like to have that
jacket
that is a badass joke yeah I'm sure you
could probably find that somewhere I
mean that movie is so famous you would
think yeah they probably sell something
like that John Smith said uh Cruz played
a vampire as I'm pretty isn't it tragic
Defoe forgot his last social Grace
centuries ago in this film that's yeah
that's a good way of putting it and like
I said I think that's what's good about
his acting performance is that you can
really believe that this dude has been
alive for thousands of years they imply
um and didn't have it doesn't have to do
normal human [__] and doesn't really
remember how to like act around people
because he doesn't have to yeah like he
doesn't have to eat he doesn't have to
do people [__] and he doesn't have to be
around them didn't have to work either
that's what I mean so he just kind of
like creeps around but that's that's
also what's kind of like tragic about
his character is that he's just creeping
around in this like old ruined Monastery
or whatever they said that's where they
found him at and you know he's just
comes out and like eats every now and
then even though he says he has like a
really great monologue at some point in
the film where he's just saying that he
used to like command armies and he had
all these retainers and drank from
Golden chalices and stuff like that and
now he's like creeping around in this
old just like eating rats and picking
off peasants and [__] like that said he
knew Play-Doh too that's what yeah that
was what was funny because like Fritz
Carrie always his character he was like
the new cinematographer and he comes in
there and he sees you know and he just
thinks that it's an actor right so the
guy's like in the coffin and he's
talking about the makeup and stuff and
then he said did you do you ever read
Plato and then he said read him I knew
him so like I said implying that he's
like really really like thousands of
years old
but that's I don't know I just think
that's probably my favorite thing about
the film it's just everything about this
movie seemed specifically calculated to
make me into because I was like this is
a movie that was made pretty much
specifically like targeted to me one of
the weird things about it or interesting
things about this movie is what they
question the vampire
about where he came from and his Origins
and everything he couldn't remember much
which makes you wonder
if you live a couple thousand years
does the brain have a limit a limit to
its storage capacity to where it was so
long ago you can't remember anymore it
just faded away
like maybe members are slowly replaced
yeah and that's why it's funny because
yeah like the two guys that are kind of
drunk and they're trying to like you
know bro out with him or whatever yeah
and you know getting him drunk on
Schnapps and they're asking us like ask
him some vampire questions and so he's
asking him it's like well how'd you get
made in a vampire and he said I don't
remember or like where where were you
born or were you born and he didn't
remember and they were just like come on
man like you know at least come up with
something but he really couldn't
remember he asked him if he made any why
doesn't he make any other vampires and
he said he's too old
can't do it and then he says I'm not
sure I've ever made any of them yeah he
said I seem to remember that I was never
able to that's right yeah yeah that's
what he said so that's the yeah so
that's another thing that they're kind
of like getting into yeah
um because he has a big long thing too
where they said oh I read that book
Dracula like myrnow gave it to me and
they asked him what he thought of it
like how like how the vampire mythology
and they're like stacked up to the real
vampire stuff and he just said that he
thought it was sad like I said yeah and
they were like why do you think it was
sad like they thought that was the
weirdest thing ever and he said he said
the thing that made him the saddest was
like the scene where Jonathan Harker
comes to Castle Dracula and Dracula has
to like make the dude food and yeah like
things like that and he's like how would
he even remember how to do that because
he hadn't had to do it for such a long
time because he doesn't eat yeah so when
he's like and now he's just he used to
command armies and now he's just like
being a servant to this human person
yeah and he found that very very sad
because it I guess it like mirrored his
own right experience because he kind of
said something about that too
but so so yeah there's like you know
considering the I don't know what it's
like the absurdity of the premise I
guess it's not as
funny as it might seem but it is funny
but like in a kind of more understated
way and I also think that
Willem Dafoe did a great job just like
giving the vampire a lot of depth and
like I said he's almost kind of like a
like a pitiful or like a pathetic
figure as well even while he's like
eating the crew and just and even though
like I said some of the situations are
just completely ridiculous he does have
some of the powers though that a
vampire's supposed to have he Froze all
what what's his name by looking at him
yeah so he does seem to have like he
doesn't seem to be like Supernatural
Supernatural but there was a scene where
John Malkovich like they they confront
him and John Malkovich actually tries to
strangle him because he's so mad yeah
and um max Shrek just like stares at him
with the crazy eyes and everything and
like giant Malcolm was just like like
and he just starts like backing away
like he like powerfully like pushed him
away kinda but he doesn't really have
like Supernatural
powers like in the book you know what I
mean well he doesn't have he doesn't
know how to how he could be destroyed he
couldn't destroy himself
yeah he gets shot and just goes You full
and attacks the guy anyway yeah he gets
shot a bunch of times though like
nothing happens
but yeah that's the thing because John
Malkovich I mean he basically says to
him he's like um you know when he was
yelling at Max track he's like Why Did
You Eat My cinematographer and all of a
sudden I told you like not to do that
it's like we had a deal and all this
other [__] and Shrek is just kind of
like well basically what are you gonna
do to me it's like you know you can't do
anything to me and you know and John
Malkovich says don't think that I can't
harm you and then Willem Dafoe says how
how would you harm me he's like I don't
even know how I would harm myself yeah
so there's just no way
so I mean but that's the whole thing and
another thing and a couple of them
threatening the vampire you're gonna do
this that the vampire was like or what
yeah yeah it's like what are you gonna
do what else what I'm a [__] vampire
you know what and burnout knew that he
knows he's a vampire and so and he knows
he doesn't really have any bargaining
really the only bargaining chip that he
has is that he promised to give him
Greta and the movie and he also promised
to give him quote unquote immortality
and you might think oh well he's already
got immortality no he didn't mean that
kind of immortality he met on film like
he was capturing him for posterity yeah
um which was very appealing yeah to
Shrek because like I said he was very
isolated and very lonely and I think it
appealed to him that
um people would be able to say that
people would be able to see him yeah and
also there was kind of like I said one
of the real sad things too is that one
of the things that he was fascinated by
was like looking at the film and he
would like look at sunrises and stuff
because he'd never seen one yeah because
he said at one point that
that was what he missed the most about
being a human was like seeing the Sun so
he could actually see it on the film so
I think that that was and like I said it
was kind of
you know the fact that this took place
like in the very early days of
filmmaking so it was still like a very
new technology so they were talking
about how
um how you know now everybody will be
able to like this we were capturing this
forever like 100 years from now 200
years from now people will still be able
to see it and like see what was
happening so and I know like I said I
think that kind of like appealed to him
and that's why he went along with myrnow
even though
he was pretty
um he was pretty recalcitrant I guess
well because he just kept saying but
like I said there's nothing that really
myrnow could do to like stop him from
snacking on the crew if he wanted to
because he pretty much started doing
that like almost immediately like he
started attack for a restored version
um wait a minute where
uh uh oh there's a 30 minute extended
version of the movie not so far too 1922
with original footage that was lost and
now found by the company Kino
International oh yeah that's right yeah
I remember hearing something about that
actually
um yeah if you saw 30 minutes long yeah
if you saw nosferati before 2007 you
probably haven't seen the entire film
yeah because some of it was I mean we're
lucky that it was that it was preserved
at all because like I said they most of
the copies were destroyed like back then
because of the copyright copyright
infringement which that's [__] crazy
but I'm just glad it survived because
it's a [__] classic Hugo said I was a
nosferati for Halloween once long coat
and roller skates for the floating
effect that's a great [__] idea
that's a great idea
slasher friend said there was an episode
of are You Afraid of the Dark called The
Midnight Madness where the character of
Dr venk shows a failing movie theater
his own version of nosferante
I don't think you know what I I remember
that show being on but I don't remember
that episode
uh John Smith says my other tragic
vampire is Eli from Let the Right One In
yeah that's a great [__] movie too I
don't think we've ever reviewed that one
I don't think Tom uh ever saw that one I
don't know if that would be his cup of
tea although I didn't know if this movie
would be his cup of tea either but I
mean we were watching it and he that was
the one that he seemed like the most
interested in like of all the ones that
I wrote down so
um and I was like hey it's free on
YouTube so we watched it and he ended up
really really liking it so I I was happy
I was like good I was like because I
[__] love this movie but I you know
you never know like I never knew if he
was gonna like it or not because I
didn't know if he would think it was too
slow or too weird or I don't really know
it's
it's not weird and I mean compared to
um you know
Elias Murphy usually like his other
movie his other famous movie begotten
which is for real like weird as [__]
um and kind of disturbing so I feel like
maybe people would think that this movie
was kind of more like that like it was
more
I'm not saying it's not kind of like art
Arty it is but it's pretty
straightforward and I think that most
people would probably enjoy it and it's
not like long it's not ponderous it's
nothing like that I think it's only like
an hour and a half or something like
that it's like just a pretty short movie
and it moves along like at a pretty good
Pace it's not
preponderous or it's not real
pretentious or anything like that
because like I said it does have this
kind of like thread of black humor
running through it just because of the
absurdity of the situation and honestly
just
watching Willem Dafoe like being the
vampire is just like that's worth the
price of admission all by itself because
he is just [__]
wildly entertaining he's just really
really entertaining just a second to get
adjusted to his accent though so if you
guys want to put subtitles on you may
want to do that yeah because everyone
kind of has like German accents and you
know none of the actors other than Udo
Kier I think are actual Germans yeah and
um
Nosferatu [__] mumbles a lot he
grumbles he says things real low so
sometimes you don't know exactly what he
said
and again because he has those teeth in
it as well so I guess that doesn't help
slasher Fred said there's also a movie
called blood the Last Vampire I've heard
of that but I've never actually seen it
um somebody said if wait a minute
Karen Lee said I like this movie now I
know the name I will watch it again
thank you yeah you should like I said
it's free on YouTube
and it's great like more people should
see it I just feel like it almost kind
of like forgotten about and that's kind
of a shame because it's like pretty rad
somebody said oh slasher friend said
since you are reviewing shadow of the
vampire one of these days you should
review the movie Hitchcock which is a
biography movie uh Hitchcock which all
about the making of psycho
I don't think that I've ever heard of
that but I sh that sounds like something
I would be really into so thank you for
that recommendation
John Smith said earlier you know your
performance is good when a horror film
performance gets an Oscar Nom the last
one was for misery
yeah
um I have to say that even though shit's
better than it used to be
horror movies still really don't get
much respect as far as
uh critics go as far as the Oscars go
like I said I think the only time a
horror movie you know won best picture
was what Silence of the Lambs
or maybe or didn't wait did get out win
because that was a horror movie that was
kind of Stepford wivese
so but yeah yeah I mean sometimes you
know I'm still mad that like [__]
Tony Collette didn't get nominated for
hereditary in 2018 because that was if
any horror performance was worth an
Oscar that [__] was so I don't know
so it's still
it's still kind of considered like a
little bit of a red-headed stepchild of
a genre a genre I guess but you couldn't
I mean Willem Dafoe in this was so good
that it's like it would have been a
crime if you'd have like overlooked the
[__] and honestly like this like I said
this got like really good um
you know uh Critic reviews reviews like
at the time Roger Ebert loved it he
picked it as one of his 10 best movies
of the year
of 2000 and he wrote like a really good
review of it which I read but yeah it's
it's just sad that it just kind of is
one of those movies that kind of fell
through the cracks I guess not from
mainstream audiences it's no it's no one
anyway for sure or not I mean yeah
obviously you're gonna enjoy it a lot
more if you know they know what about
nosferatio and if you know about murnau
and if you know about like stuff if
you're interested in that like the early
days of filmmaking then yeah it's going
to be a lot more interesting to you than
otherwise yeah and obviously the humor
is going to be a lot funnier and stuff
like that but
I mean so so according to this movie the
movie Nosferatu was a documentary [__]
happened
that's the best part of it that I
thought that was the best angle I mean
they pretty much all well they didn't
all get killed at the end but a bunch of
people did get killed like in the last
scene like Greta got killed yeah
um the vampire got killed Udo here got
killed yeah
um Fritz got killed yeah like pretty
much everybody got killed but the thing
about it like I said all of the people
that are in this movie
are playing actual people
um and Wikipedia was very uh was very
nice to point out that all of those real
people actually did like live much
longer that they didn't die like on the
you know it's like someone lived into
the 70s or 80s uh so it's fine they're
like actually the the one that died the
earliest was murnau himself he died in a
car accident in 1931. so only about 10
years after this movie was made but the
rest of the people you know that are
portrayed in this movie actually most of
them live you know and had careers until
like the 50s 60s 70s and I think a
couple of them even lived into the 80s
so there was that too but and another
thing that they said that they thought
was kind of interesting was that Greta
yeah look at her she's like hey look how
sweet I look at that little face look at
that little face
Greta what she um
uh in this movie they kind of portray
her as like this big famous star because
even like the vampire knows who she is
and he's like hey that's Greta what's
her face or whatever and um they're like
in real life she was in a lot more
movies like after Nosferatu but she
wasn't as famous as this movie made her
appear but she was in other movies like
up until the 50s but not very often like
she was just kind of in a movie here and
there like up until the 1950s and then I
think she retired
but so this movie made her seemed like
because she was like a super diva and
she had like with the two dogs and it's
like hey hold this dog and hold that dog
you know when she was like super snotty
and everything like that so they kind of
made her that kind of character but yeah
I mean if you haven't seen it it's free
on YouTube it's [__] great
um but especially if you're into silent
film or are interested in that kind of
stuff like you know early film
or vampires or vampires or are you just
like Willem Dafoe and John Malkovich and
want to see them like throw down
because those are like the best scenes
of the movie I think like when the two
of them are [__] arguing and [__]
like that although I think my favorite
scene in the whole movie is the one
where um and the other guy are like
getting drunk and they're asking Max
Shrek they're trying to hang out the
vampire they're trying to like hang out
they're like asking vampire questions
and like and the [__] that he says it's
just like it's just so so funny like I
said it's not zany funny but it's just
funny almost like sad funny or like
blackly funny it's just kind of like
that
um let me see John Smith said I like to
think Shrek's accent would be weird if
you were centuries old your accent would
be strange yeah
um
yeah Winterfell forever said I think
Essie Davis should have gotten the Oscar
too for the babadook that was shameful
yeah she was also really great in that
so like I said there's a lot of great
and I think I've said this before but I
would argue
that a lot of times I think if you have
a really good performance in a horror
movie I think it's harder to be in a
horror movie because the emotions are
you know it's a horror movie so your
emotions are going to be like a lot more
heightened so you have to like portray a
lot more heightened emotions believably
which to me seems harder than just like
being in a drama where you're just not
really doing much of anything you know
what I mean so I don't know I I kind of
feel like it should be appreciated more
but whatever maybe they should have like
a separate category or something that
would probably make me happy but uh all
right so are we ready to wrap it up for
this evening yeah
okay so it's Sunday night which means
tomorrow is Monday and that means
tomorrow is a haunting Mondays and the
um episode that we're doing is season
seven episode five
four or five I can't remember it's
called ashes of evil uh which I didn't
remember it like when I was looking at
pictures but then we were watching and
I'm like oh yeah I remember this one
this is actually like a pretty decent
episode it happened in Tennessee I think
but yeah so we're gonna be talking about
that one tomorrow so hopefully you guys
can join us for that
and uh so have a good rest of your
Sunday evening you guys and we will see
you again tomorrow good night